for the last few years i've been a
writer in residence at the stanford
medical school
i was hired by an incredible woman she's
a poet and an anesthesiologist named
audrey schaefer
and she started the medicine and the
muse program to reintroduce humanities
back into medical education
and training my job was to teach writing
storytelling and general communication
skills to physicians
nurses medical students and other health
care workers and i thought i'd get a ton
of great student essays about dissecting
cadavers and
poems about the spleen and i did
but almost immediately i started getting
more essays that made me really anxious
and really worried my students were
writing about their crushing anxiety
the unbearable pressure on them to
succeed their mental health diagnoses
their suicide attempts how alone and
isolated they felt
and wondered if they'd gone into the
right profession and they weren't even
doctors yet
this is my student uriel sanchez the
choice you are given through medicine
from a lot of your mentors even is like
you have to choose
like being a really good person or a
really good doctor
physicians own humanity and emotional
well-being are almost never made a core
part of their training
or even acknowledged and real
vulnerability like
sharing certain mental health diagnoses
for example can be
absolutely career ending but nearly 30
percent of american medical students are
depressed
and one in 10 have thought about suicide
and it's actually even worse for
practicing physicians
there's really widespread job
dissatisfaction high rates of depression
and doctors have one of the highest
suicide rates of any profession in the
united states
this is scary not just for them but for
us too
i really think doctors have the most
important job
and if their lives are at stake ours are
too
now i am absolutely not a mental health
professional
i'm a writer which most days is
absolutely the complete and total
opposite
um but i can tell you that the more
opportunities that i give health care
workers
to share their daily frustrations their
fears their joys what surprises them
what they resent
the better they seem to feel so at
medicine the muse we offer evening
weekend and day-long storytelling
workshops at farms
and other places with really good food i
invite other journalists
writers producers podcasters and poets
and they teach writing communication and
storytelling skills to our participants
and those participants practice being
vulnerable by sharing their stories out
loud with one another
and in doing so they reconnect with what
drew them to medicine in the first place
these are the skills they'll draw on
when they realize and are confronted
with the stressful messy reality of the
work they've chosen
this is how they realize it's a calling
so i have a prescription here for you
today
it's not from physicians it's for them
and i ask my students for help and
before i start let me just say i work
with doctors
but i'm absolutely convinced that this
applies to almost any profession
especially those of us who are so
committed to our work
and it can be so intense and
overwhelming that sometimes
we forget why we chose to do it in the
first place to me
sharing a true vulnerable story is a lot
like
raising a flag up a flagpole other
people see it
if they agree with it and it resonates
with them they come and stand under it
with you
that's what my student maite van
hentenrich did
i mean it was super anxiety inducing and
i shared parts of myself that i really
have probably told
five classmates
when maite was a baby she had to have
her leg amputated
when she got to medical school she was
taking just a standard class quiz
and she got asked the question please
tell us about the first time you
encountered someone with a disability
she wondered if her supervisors had ever
considered that the person with a
disability was her
the doctor so she talked about it in
front of about a hundred of her friends
and peers which is a big deal because
you know she's really shy
and afterwards what happened is a number
of students with disabilities that she
didn't know
came up to her and asked her to co-lead
a group on campus that's now advocating
for more visibility and inclusion in
medical training
in english we tend to call people
creatives if they have a certain job
like designer or architect or artist
i hate that term i think it's offensive
and exclusionary creativity doesn't
belong to a certain group of people
a lot of my work with physicians and
medical students is just reminding them
that no matter what profession that we
choose
we can make meaning find beauty in the
hard stuff
and create this is medical student pablo
romano my parents immigrated here from
mexico many years ago
and when i was in college they passed
away
i was 18 when my dad died and then 20
when my mom died
not only has pablo been talking publicly
for the first time about being an
orphan but together we started a live
storytelling series we're calling talk
rx and it's become a really popular
place for his peers to share their most
vulnerable and powerful
thoughts and feelings i go to a school
that cares so much about data and
research and numbers
at the end of the day what moves people
is stories
arafin rahman is a second year medical
student
and before she was born her parents
immigrated from bangladesh
to the united states she grew up in a
really beautiful home in northern
california
very safe and stable her parents are
still together uh
she never went hungry and she graduated
from harvard
i didn't feel like the stories i had
were worth telling
or that they mattered arafain did have
stories though
recently she gave a talk about being
maybe the only bangladeshi american girl
to win an essay contest from the
daughters of the american revolution
and then dress up for halloween as the
declaration of independence
and i love our fiend story so much
because to me it represents
all that is good and bad and hard and
exhausting
about representing the new american
dream
the hardest thing was coming up against
that voice that was telling me
no one wants to hear my stories like why
invest the time
and this thing that doesn't really mean
anything in the grand scale of life
maybe the biggest thing is like maybe it
does
[Music]
life is so short for me
the only thing really that matters with
my time here
is feeling like i can connect with other
people
and maybe make them feel slightly less
alone and
in my experience that's what stories do
absolutely the best
so my student and a collaborator in a
lot of these
endeavors is a candace kim she's an
md phd student in medical education
she's written about me too in medicine
navigating her queer identity in a
conservative field
and her mom's metastatic cancer
diagnosis and recently she started also
doing some really interesting
research about our work we've seen that
students who participate
in our storytelling opportunities show
between
a 36 and 51 decrease in distress
if this was a mental health drug it
would be an absolute
blockbuster results seem to last
up to a month it might be longer a month
is just when
candace stopped measuring so we don't
even know not only that but 100
of our participants recommend these
opportunities to a friend
for me though the most important thing
that our work has done
is create a culture of vulnerability in
a place that there was absolutely
none before i think what this does
is that it allows doctors and other
folks an opportunity to envision a
different kind of future for themselves
and their patients this is my tea again
i want to be the doctor that
remembers when your birthday is without
having to look at the chart
and want to be the doctor who knows what
my
patient's favorite color is and what tv
shows they like to watch
i want to be the doctor that's
remembered for listening to people
and making sure i take care of all of
them and not
just treating their disease being human
is a terminal condition we all have it
and we are all going to die
helping healthcare professionals
communicate more meaningfully
with each other with their patients and
with themselves is
certainly not going to magically change
everything that is wrong with a
contemporary health care system
and it's not going to lift the immense
burdens that we place on our physicians
but it is absolutely key in making sure
that our healers are healthy enough to
heal the rest of us
communicating with each other with
vulnerability listening with compassion
is i believe the absolute best best
medicine that we have
thank you